[Music]  recent years have seen a boom in charger  types for phones tablets laptops cameras  and more  all those different cables were bad for  the environment and meant you could get  in a bit of a tangle now Parliament has  passed rules to standardize charges for  electronic devices a one-size-fits-all  solution for the EU the USBC  many old obsolete or unused charges  ended up in landfill across the EU more  than 11 000 tons of charges are thrown  out every year the new rules will reduce  waste from Autumn 2024 all new products  will use the USBC Port consumers will be  able to choose whether to buy a new  device with or without a charger meaning  fewer charges manufactured and fewer  ending up in the bin a bag full of  different charges for different devices  will become a thing of the past the EU  will monitor advances in technology to  ensure all manufacturers continue to use  the same charges across their product  ranges  [Music]